[موسيقى]
بالنسبه للمتلازمه اللي حضرتك بتقول عليها
دي انا ما سمعتش قبل كده عنها غير من
حضرتك دلوقتي فانا ما اعرفهاش قبل كده
يعني هنا الشخص او الراجل بشكل مخصص يعني
بيبقى عايز يحتفظ بطفولته ما يبقاش يتحمل
مسؤوليه يفضل محتفظ بالمتعه بدون مسؤوليات
فكره ان هو يفضل لسه صغير ما يتنقلش
المرحله الاداء والواجبات وهكذا لا والله
انا اول مره اسمع عن حاجه اسمها متلازمه
البيطار بان مش كرتون تقريبا مش عارف ايه
بيتك مهندس الصراحه يعني تقريبا ان الواحد
يبقى الطفل طول عمره حتى بعد ما يكبر
اعتقد ان هو مرض
تقريبا اللي هو ذات تصايب الرجال اللي هو
الناس الكبيره مثلا مش عاوزه تعيش سنها
المقصود بها ايه انا معرفش حقيقي ما قراتش
عنها ما اعرفش ايه الموضوع بتاعها يعني
[موسيقى]